i'm about to disappoint many of you and
here's why
i've been getting a lot of messages from
people email text you know instagram
facebook saying pat just stay in your
lane why are you talking about politics
all these podcast video stuff about
trump biden election
taxes just talk business we followed you
because of entrepreneurship we followed
you because of some of your interviews
stop talking politics stay in your lane
so i wanted to use this moment this
platform here to share with you and kind
of clarify
our relationship together so there are a
lot of different kinds of people that
follow my content
number one there are those of you who
found me five years ago after watching
life of an entrepreneur in 90 seconds
there are those of you who watch all the
business sales and entrepreneur content
i put up
some of you enjoy watching the breakdown
videos i have on different topics u.s
china trade war brexit venezuela history
of usa on conflict
minimum wage etc some of you watch the
bodybuilding interviews
some watch the mob interviews some of
you like the motivation monday videos
some read the book your next five moves
some attended the vault conference
some of you accidentally follow me
because someone recommended it
there are some of you that work with me
currently or used to work within the
past
some of you sincerely hate what i have
to say and want to find ways to
undermine any positions i may have
then there's those who agree or disagree
with me politically
last but not least there are those of
you that are diehard valuetainers and
value
my approach look regardless of which one
you are whether you're the person that
puts negative commentary positive you're
a die hard valentine
whoever you are just the fact they took
the time to watch my content
put a like subscribe comment positive or
negative
i appreciate you because the most
valuable thing you got is time
and for you to give me your time that
means a lot to me but having said that
i also want to prepare you for a
relationship moving forward
i'm very comfortable in my own skin i'm
very comfortable knowing you may or may
not be in my life five to ten years from
now
i'm very comfortable knowing at some
point you will disagree with my views if
you haven't already done so
i'm very comfortable knowing i don't
walk on water i'm very comfortable
knowing i don't have all the answers
i'm very comfortable knowing i'm
extremely confident
in my abilities to reason any topic as
long as i put the right amount
of time researching i'm very comfortable
knowing that just like the iphone ios
system keeps upgrading and fixing new
bugs
i'll be doing the same as well i'm very
comfortable knowing most people in the
world
lack the ability to reason logically
instead most reason emotionally i'm okay
with that
i'm very comfortable knowing that god
gave me the life that he gave me for a
reason
i'm committed to being one of his best
soldiers this generation has ever seen
i'm very comfortable knowing that some
of my views will face opposition
and last but not least if some of the
content you've been watching lately is a
little too much maybe it's too extreme
and it's kind of bothering you
i just want you to know hearing it from
my mouth we're about to double down on
that content okay
and we're just getting warmed up so i'm
saying this to you because our
relationship matters to me a lot so if
you don't like my approach
i highly suggest you unfollow now
however
if you like authenticity if you like
somebody that's willing to share with
them what's on their mind
if you like somebody that doesn't want
to bs you or play around with your time
you may want to stick around because
this is going to be a very
wild ride but regardless i'm not just
going to shut up and dribble we're going
to keep doing what we're doing right now
either way
i appreciate your time you mean a lot to
me
if this relationship continues
phenomenal if it doesn't i'm okay with
it as well
love you take care bye